stated clearly presents
what is the rna world hypothesis
if you were to go back in time 120
million years
you'd find yourself in a dinosaur world
500 million years ago was a world of
trilobites and other strange sea
creatures
3.4 billion years ago was the world of
the first living cells
and if you were to go back further still
scientists suspect that chains of a
chemical called rna
or something similar to rna kickstarted
this entire beautiful mess
that we call life
rna is thought to have given rise to
life for several reasons
chains of rna are found abundantly in
all living cells today
rna is a close chemical cousin to dna
and with very little help from
researchers rna chains can replicate
evolve and interact with their
environments
while many details have yet to be worked
out the rna world hypothesis
is the simple idea that somewhere on our
early planet perhaps in a tide pool or
hot spring
the earth's chemistry was producing
random chains of rna
once formed they began replicating
evolving
and competing with each other for
survival as these chains evolved and
diversified
some eventually began cooperating to
produce the genetic code
a wide array of complex proteins and
even living cells which
from the perspective of rna can actually
be thought of as houses
or survival machines for rna to live
inside
to understand how rna chains can
interact with their environments
replicate and evolve we first need to
understand the simple process
of base pairing chains of rna are made
of nucleotides
small molecules that come in four
different types labeled a
c u and g the backbone atoms of a
nucleotide
shown here as a yellow bar can form
strong chemical bonds with the backbone
atoms of any other rna nucleotide
this means that different chains can
have completely different sequences from
left to right
the parts we call the bases of
nucleotides the colored sections labeled
a
c u or g are attracted to other bases
sort of like a magnet but they're
selective about who they will stick to
g selectively pairs with c a selectively
pairs with u
when bases find their matches and stick
together we call it base pairing
researchers have found that with a
little bit of assistance base pairing
allows chains of rna to replicate and
evolve here's how it works
when a long chain of rna is suspended in
cool water with high concentrations of
free nucleotides
the chain can act as a template for its
own replication
nucleotides automatically base pair with
their partners on the existing chain
if their backbone atoms form chemical
bonds with each other
and by the way this is the part that
currently requires assistance from
researchers
we're not yet sure how this would have
happened in the wild a complementary rna
strand is born
one with the exact inverse sequence of
the original
if the water is then heated paired bases
lose their grip
allowing both chains to act as templates
when the cycle repeats
the great thing about this process is
that every other rna chain produced is a
copy of the original
but sometimes mutations slip in
this means that as chains compete for
survival and reproduction
true evolution descent with modification
acted upon by selection
can operate on chains of rna
as amazing as replication is base
pairing also gives rna chains a second
special ability
when placed in water cool enough for
base pairing but without enough free
nucleotides for replication
chains will fold up and base pair with
themselves
the end result is a complex shape with
certain sticky bases pointing outward
because they weren't able to find
partners these sticky outward facing
bases can cause unique chemical
reactions
by interacting with other molecules in
their environment
a folded chain of rna capable of guiding
a specific chemical reaction
is what we call a ribozyme
some ribozymes break certain molecules
apart others join certain molecules
together
a ribozyme specific function is
determined by its specific
shape and its shape is determined by its
sequence
if a mutation changes a ribozyme
sequence the shape can be modified
and so can its function when ribozymes
were first discovered
scientists wondered how difficult it
would be for random chains of rna to
evolve legitimate survival functions
imagine for example a ribozyme that
could build nucleotides
out of molecules it finds in its
environment across multiple generations
natural selection could promote and
refine this ribozyme because the chain
would tend to have access to more free
nucleotides than its rivals
allowing it to replicate more often to
explore this idea
researchers at simon fraser university
produced a large group of random rna
chains
and examined them to see if any happen
to be able to make nucleotides
surprisingly some actually could but
they weren't very efficient
researchers selected out the successful
chains and then used a lab technique
called pcr
to quickly replicate them with slight
random mutations
after just 10 rounds of pcr followed by
selection
highly efficient nucleotide-building
ribozymes evolved
these are molecules with a life-like
ability to actively participate in their
own survival
these ribozymes and many others produced
through similar experiments
are beginning to blur the line between
living things and simple chemistry
so to sum things up the rna world
hypothesis is the simple idea that the
first things to replicate and evolve on
our planet
may have been chains of rna or something
similar to them
while the basic idea of the rna world
does seem to give us a promising pathway
to the origin of life
it's still very much a work in progress
as mentioned
one of several unsolved problems is how
did nature get backbone binding to
function without the special enzymes or
lab techniques we use today
while many researchers continue to focus
on rna others are investigating
alternative molecules
chemical systems that might replicate
and evolve without assistance
and could have given rise to rna
continual breakthroughs are being found
in both avenues of research
i'm john perry and that's the rna world
hypothesis
stated clearly
this video was funded by the center for
chemical evolution
the national science foundation and nasa
though we do receive grants from time to
time stated clearly is made possible
with financial contributions from
viewers like you
to support us visit our website at
statedclearly.com and click
contribute i'm happy to announce that
you can now also support us on
patreon.com
so long for now stay curious